[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey we all shouted hey hey I don't know
which one we're doing don't jump up and
shout out I was born in 2004. welcome
back oh you're the youngest person on
the break room I've been telling you
guys
uh younger than Brandon welcome back to
the break room you guys our daily show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know
um coming up today we're going to be
talking about crew three
is that nerdiness we're talking about
exactly we're gonna be talking about
exactly the nerd party well I take that
news
With Arms Wide Open
oh creep
um
waiting for Jonathan majors
a horny show already
those pictures today we're gonna be
talking about Cat Cora the director for
She-Hulk she has a lot of interviews
where she's explaining a lot of new
stuff that's actually pretty cool uh
Rihanna's awake and ready to come back
to music you guys
we don't know where she's been blessings
I meant like entertainment wise even
Fenty and Savage Savvy Savage Fenty have
been like where is she what is she doing
yeah she's having a baby but I need her
back to music okay I want her to
continue giving hot women lingerie that
they have to post on Instagram as like a
quid pro quo and hot dudes I have some
fancy draws myself okay all right I read
one day the biggest scam on the internet
the biggest game on the internet is she
gets uh women to wear bras that she's
never gonna wear and I was like yep
that's true Jonathan Majors is Bill's
Mafia if you can confirm that for me
Daniel Santos you will uh I'll uh know a
high five years and then we're going to
welcome Harrison Ford to the MCU you
guys and we make deals with the devil
but first let me introduce everyone
that's on today who cares about me we
got Eric I care about you oh and so does
the internet hey internet hi we got Mr
Tommy Victorian I care about you too boo
I think about you every day what about
night
that we got oh I think about you at
night too
hello happy to be here
very excited you know he don't think
about you at all I don't know I do think
about you I was I had a lot to say and
all of a sudden just Lara strong popped
into my head oh I remember what happened
last night and I couldn't shake It Go
tune into our weekly podcast uh fantasy
oh my God talking dragons uh our fantasy
after show where we talk Dragon [ __ ]
fantasy is my nightly podcast where I
talk about you
and still horny horny upset no I don't
think it was about that I think it's
about love for every 100 you guys we're
gonna give you some motivational
speeches out of the boo bucket do we
want to give like a little example a
blue bucket so these are motivational
speeches if you're being chased by yes
this this famous movie horror movie
villain okay so if I if you're being
chased by Leatherface Texas Chainsaw
Massacre I'd be like hey I I know you
got a homicidal maniac coming after you
and he's got a weird thing on his face
he's got a thing full of chainsaws maybe
his family invited you to dinner and it
smelled really bad because there's dead
animals everywhere but hey you're
already in Texas and that's a hell ho as
it is so good luck to you
run run to the closest Whataburger hope
you make it inside yeah oh I do I you do
have Whataburger in Texas but they've
they've expanded outside the States you
don't have to go to Texas now I'll add
to that and whatever you do don't run up
the stairs every time you run up the
stairs you're just gonna get caught you
can't come back down the stairs he's
already halfway there oh we'll get into
it is Leatherface like a cow though you
take a cow upstairs
he stands outside the doors
not fair her come back up here come back
up here
is he can idiot he doesn't have anything
what are you running about down there
hey sorry about the stabbing sorry about
the stabbing you guys let's get into our
headlines
gently into the headlines
um so our first headline you guys
whoo those three three photos drop my
switch seats because I know you're going
to want to see thank you thank you thank
you so sorry you got to sit in The
Thirst chair I love that that's the
first chair oh my God she wants to see
the photos the Creed Three photos
dropped and boy these are like the film
posters do we have a little image
Heavens to better it looks a little
heavy do we have any draw the major
photos oh do we know what John the
majors playing
not exactly we've heard some oh they
haven't said it all it's someone from uh
Adonis Creed's pass oh okay there was it
was rumored originally although this is
the first one kind of being done outside
of Sylvester Stallone's involvement at
all right he's producing but he's not in
it but there's a rumor that it was going
to be Clubber Lang like like someone
related to clever Lang Mr T's character
I believe Rocky which is I really think
Rocky III is an underrated Rocky movie
because Clubber Lang is a great villain
he insults Adrian he like he like he
like he like he goes after Rocky's wife
he like kind of like charges at both of
them in like a very menacing man he's
just like he's like one of those it's
like how boxing used to be when they
would talk so much then kind of MMA took
over for it but anyway if he is related
to clever language that would be a great
that'd be really cool now I'm not very
familiar with the rules of boxing but
are there only like certain households
that are allowed to be involved in the
Game of Thrones can anyone else come in
here could this be one of Apollo Creed's
bastards left out there in the world
you know I'm still on the house of the
Dragons yeah another creep and he's like
I got left in the streets I didn't grow
up with a silver spoon in my mouth like
you did poor Felicia Rashad is gonna
have to take in another non-biological
jail I will also raise you I'll raise
you wish my husband didn't go over to
Russia and get killed but by tough
longer I will say this has been quite a
couple of weeks for Michael or uh for uh
Jonathan Majors is a great spread of
men's health and even those posters I
mean Michael B Jordan looks good but
like
one of the majors is like if you think
this version of me is ripped just wait
until the next one comes along there are
many other Jonathan Mages out there
um okay we got another headline for you
headline number two the She-Hulk
director cat coiro had a post-credit
scene for episode 8 which would have
given one of you guys extra money when
she or extra points someone said that we
were gonna end episode 8 with the
postgres scene and we did it but this is
the second to last episode right okay
and we actually were supposed to have
one in an interview with the direct oh I
should look at this one now I'm sorry in
an interview with the direct Cat Cora
revealed that Daredevil's Walk of Shame
was originally supposed to be the
post-credit reveal she adds it played
rhythmically better to be the way it is
which is like yeah because I guess it
wouldn't have been a reveal because we
would have known it would have been
insinuated they had sex yeah they could
have just done hand stuff that's true
they could have done hand stuff so we
know that it was sex stuff because of
the walking shame
yeah yeah hand stuff is definitely a 207
am like yeah I actually have a sleeping
yeah Daredevil would have been like oh
you you can't hear this because you
don't have super sensitive here like I
do but no uh my phone is ringing out of
the room I left my microwaves
I gotta go anyway let's get rhythmically
better
um
third headline and by the way I want to
say thank you to the to the producer and
camera crew of the break room who
adjusted those cameras on the Fly after
I just shifted the seating let's switch
shut up everybody switch uh change
places Cat Cora also mentions the idea
of the design she had for scar
originally she said I had an idea that I
wanted scar to be a toddler like a baby
Yoda kind of character but I don't think
that's where the story is hit I like
that she's just like in most of her
interviews like I don't really care what
it's supposed to be well that's what I
wanted it this the same situation kind
of happened with one division where they
were like it was way after the fact that
the head writer was like we didn't read
any of the comics it was confusing we
don't know how like things work in it so
we didn't really know any of the
characters but which I give credit to
for She-Hulk for knowing the characters
I think Kat Courier the director was
like yeah it's a
Glitz like well scarred in the comics
ages so fast you it has to be like a
teenager he's like 190 right he's older
them well even uh grogu or his cat says
baby Yoda yeah he's 55 years old he's
not even a time that's true yeah yeah
yeah get cat on the phone I got a
complain you want me to call her I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go Angry nerd on her
I gotta battle last
cat hell no
that was Rush not my quiro oh no okay
Jessica wants to leave after sitting in
this chair I don't know how to feel
someone James that's the King's throne
that's the queen's throne uh someone
shiny Shack said switching seats may be
a fun Super Chat goal that would be a
very fun keep that in mind let's note
that producers love that so much John's
like Jessica don't really don't ever
move again don't address the chat in
their stupid ideas trash bag by the way
Monday's trash night don't forget to put
yourselves in your homes
she also mentions in the same direct
article as before uh they were gonna
give Edward Norton a cameo in She-Hulk
they were discussing it she says there's
a lot of talk about the fact that the
last time they were together a different
actor was playing The Hulk and Mark made
quite a few jokes about that and we did
entertain the idea of swapping Mark out
for Edward Norton but that did not come
to pass uh because Edward Norton was
like get the F away from me I'm gonna
burn you with a cigarette if you ask me
again did you come into the show no I
bet I bet I would want to do it this was
Edward Norton this morning when he was
going through his iPad and he he
obviously has Google alert set up first
time oh yeah and he's like seeing this
and he's like reading he's like
are you okay I'm sorry the thing is I'm
like don't ever spill one Army again but
remember when I was doing this to you
I already drank out of this I thought
this was
I just won't drink water okay that's
fine I kind of spit enough Jessica you
moved to this seat and this seat's in
the Splash Zone oh
what is what what's Tommy doing to that
poor mug tell me we had HR training
about how to take that about the mug of
milk okay next headline what do you
think about Mother's Milk it's mother
it's milk with the puppy
uh Rihanna oh speaking of great speaking
of the greatest Rihanna is rumored to
have music in wakanda Forever
this is uh you can clearly tell which
headlines I forced to be put in it
excuse me okay Rihanna is being rumored
to have music in wakanda Forever it's
rumored to be the post credits or not
the post credit but in the credit scene
and one other song in the actual film
itself which means this could be the
music that's gonna play at the Super
Bowl well call me rude boy but I am
excited about that shut up and drive me
they had to work too hard
well you know I'm unfaithful yeah time
to replay do it again
SOS please someone help me
umbrella
guys that's a beautiful show [ __ ]
better have my money drop some super
chats
no Jessica you said uh this could be the
music for the super so you're saying she
might have a new song that would
Premiere in this movie and then she
would sing it again at the Super Bowl
okay okay whatever it is Rihanna we want
you to stay
do we know if Kendrick Lamar is doing
any music for this I mean he did the he
did that in the trailer then like he did
the whole album pretty much for the
first movie yeah it sounds like they're
mixing it up maybe I think they are
which is also a really good idea because
I think the first album made so much
money why not Branch out and go to more
black artists that can also spread the
one maybe Kendrick was like I don't want
to write a whole other album Kendrick
did uh just do the short film Anna album
and so he's probably also still on tour
doing that stuff last I saw uh it's a
great great great short film
um oh yeah cake Corey good song
for something yeah what does it stand
for it kick
eatingly okay I think Rihanna needs to
work on that one Russian ass killing
everyone
that's what Master T says killing
everyone
that doesn't really work well in the RAP
Community when I call myself
Master P but that that's different you
know what everybody reads too far into
this we're too woke these days catch up
on Tommy Talks weeknights at seven on
Fox Nation
I hope that's you next Nation
coming up next on gutfield
no it's Garfield on my station it's the
cat and he's even worse
all right you want to talk
I hope they pull like a Spider-Man one
you know maybe Spiderman one and they
have Rihanna show up a la Macy Gray at
the parade and maybe Rihanna's there
singing a song at the parade and then
Neymar shows up and he makes a wave come
by and she goes yo it's away and like
that's that's her part I don't want that
but speaking of wakanda forever
battleship
well she was in Boston yeah
I'm crying
she's only seen three movies as far as
get up battleship because she was in it
and Wreck-It Ralph
2.0
oh she walked out in the middle she's
like this is nothing like the board game
though like Rihanna you were there in
the movie I was told this was about the
board game she watched all of oceans
though
um okay
other headline Trevor Noah make Cameo
and wakanda forever you guys I think
this rumor has been out for a minute but
I found out some news today that I don't
know a lot of people knew he PL okay so
in uh wakanda forever he's rumored to
play his character is called grito
greito g-r-i-t-o
um and that character is basically level
wakanda Suri Siri Siri is wakanda's Siri
it's an AI Tech it's kind of like Jarvis
was the Iron Man and so this would be
Trevor Noah's character to wakanda and
he plays the character in the first
movie just the voice yeah just the voice
but he was uncredited until it came out
in like on like DVD right yeah yeah he
wasn't credited in the film but when it
went out on like DVD release they had
his name in the credits as his voice if
you remember in the film whenever Ross
is like playing the video game helping
to fly the ship there's a voice telling
him like oh they're shooting at the the
lab you got to get out and he's like no
I'm gonna stay I'm gonna help these
people uh he's Doom watch out oh my God
put it on some merch some break room
merch
you hear me
Philip are you out there watching put it
on some merch print it up put it on it
blurpo it's me blurpo so and we think as
far as we know that
grito was created for the film ah right
well if you find it anywhere in like
Marvel Comics but it is based off of uh
something from African yeah it was like
a West African like Storyteller the word
comes from like really glad we got that
piece of information out before I made
agrito grito yeah don't don't do
anything there's no need this side of
the table well I'm Jessica Clement so it
doesn't matter wait a minute we switched
Souls when I came into this scene so I
like the comments why am I so horny for
Tommy all of a sudden someone said why
is bech told on Clemens aside and
Clemens on bech told sign they said
Brandon fixed it if I can fix these
things I would I would I would I would
you guys you got to say the magic words
and then we'll switch back
tread carefully Master C I'm not saying
any magic words
and other headline news logisin two has
rap production According to some
Instagram and Twitter posts from
different crew members they have
confirmed it's done shooting John we
don't have the photos right okay perfect
so but it is like it's like the hair
makeup team
oh they were deleted
I guess that makes sense when I clicked
the link and I found uh the post they
were I thought they were tweeted by the
people but they must have been like
screenshotted and tweeted by other
people being like here's the Tweet so
they've been deleted probably because
they did not want people to know that it
finished shooting but it has rap
shooting I mean it's due to come out
next summer it hasn't been it wasn't
pushed no that has not been pushed uh
they showed some footage at like d23 uh
and I'm sure there's plenty of
post-production I need to be done now
I'm sure there's a lot of stuff they got
to do okay all right so and which we
this is this is breaking this is
breaking this is breaking news breaking
news breaking news on a break room
because we talked about this we
theorized it on Friday but it has been
confirmed that Harrison Ford is going to
be playing Thunderbolt Ross for a new
world order and it was and when I say
break in is because it wasn't alleged it
was a rumor on Friday when we were
talking about it but right now it is
today by Dead uh
reported that he will be showing up and
appearing as Thunderbolt Ross in New
World Order if you guys want to know our
theories and our thoughts on it go back
to Friday's break room it was very funny
do we have the image
you need an image of Harrison I'm just
excited from my cake eater to my seat
heater you know oh my gosh oh and also
Carl lumbley is also confirmed to be a
new world order oh yeah Falcon Winter
Soldier yeah yeah we do that from d23
well I thought they just said e-liver no
I guess they said both of them right
wasn't he there maybe he was he was it
was a blur how big is this candy I'm
supposed to be just talking to Sam
Wilson no he was there because remember
you I was like I forgot that he was
actually not as old as he was on the
show they aged him up like because he
looks so good on stage like he was like
really thick yeah yeah he was looking to
go they made him look so much I mean I
want to see some like flashbacks with
him in action yeah I want to see yeah
when like Bucky's like we fight the
thing is in Korea I was like let's see
it show us the thing is he looks so good
for his HD I know he can do everything
like he can do backflips jumps he's
amazing you can do it um he's gonna
punch Harrison Ford in the same face but
he's not yeah isn't going to fall on the
ground no he's not he's done falling for
us yeah I'm falling for him oh what's
new he'll be on Tommy Talks tonight on
Fox Nation
after Dark
Michael giaccino has told us he's not
he's not doing blade you guys he said
I'm not doing blade you guys stop asking
he actually said uh Michael giacchino is
the director from uh werewolf by night
correct is the director from werewolf by
night sorry I didn't say that first he
said I mean look I love blade
[Music]
look I love blade I think it's an
amazing amazing character it's one of my
favorites but I feel like that thing is
already emotion in a way that is like
and I'm in motion on other things as
well and there's just it's a whole you
know it's just timing wise it's a little
crazy so I feel like you know I want to
be I want it to be a great movie I want
that to be an awesome movie because that
character deserves it in a huge way but
yeah right now I mean no wow the right
now at the end kind of I think he was
too he didn't want to come off as
offensive about it he was like I'm gonna
make sure I load it up with a lot of
word vomit and then say yeah no well so
he's probably scoring the Batman 2 right
lately because he did the Batman score
and that was pretty popular I'm sure
he's got plenty of like yeah I can't
imagine he's hurting for work right now
right right but yeah and there were
reports that he they'd wanted to put
blade in werewolf by night to do like a
little Cameo there and it like didn't
work out or like he wasn't allowed to do
it uh but this is a very evasive answer
I think yeah uh and you know I think we
were kind of talking around the office
like werewolf by night a little
different than like tackling like a
blade movie which would be a lot more
you know werewolf by night was great we
all loved it awesome very quick little
movie didn't have to do much character
development pretty pretty much isolated
to a couple of locations the blade movie
is going to be a lot I'm wondering if
the blade movie is turning into the like
Don Quixote of MCU everyone who tries to
make this movie just like cannot make it
work where's your Ali's just hanging out
in his trailer like someone put a script
together someone gave me a direction
it's hard okay you guys I'm I'm a a
breakdown I'm coming out with soon is of
Blade the 1998 first place and you saw
probably on Instagram if you follow me
that I've been watching it this weekend
and it's such a good meaty movie that
I'm like my first instinct was like how
are they gonna redo this how are they
going to read it so I think they are
like a little nervous it's a lot of
hands and it's like we need to make sure
it's good this is the first MCA movie
that brought us back onto the map like I
just need we need to make sure it's good
and it has so many good dialogues that
they need to put in I mean that is the
movie that saved yeah Marvel Studios
before it was what it was like it kind
of showed that you could make these kind
of movies because everyone thought it
was not gonna work they made three like
for a franchise
three theatrical releases you know I
mean yeah by the time you get to play
Trinity maybe maybe it's more about the
star power than it is yeah
I think also it might be a situation you
know with pressure wise kind of like
Fantastic Four like we've had two
Fantastic Four movies they were beloved
in the early Arts but like doing an MCU
version has a lot of pressure they're
really you know Persnickety about the
script and the director and making sure
it's way better than its predecessor so
you know they might be buying their time
because there was such a little pressure
with like a Guardians of the Galaxy and
stuff like that right yeah no one
thought it was gonna work but it worked
great sure did so apocalypse wow yeah
they said plus Wesley Snipes is a great
actor martial artist yep uh yes
re-watching Wesley Snipes I was like man
I missed this man so so much he's so
alive what
Wesley sniper
bring him back from the great beyond
guys prayers up to Snipes bony horses in
the chat bony horses I will say Mercy
Williams saying they're trying to figure
out how to make it appropriate for kids
instead of just making it rated R I
guarantee you they're not trying to make
blade for kids I think they know they're
gonna split the difference is yeah I
want to see some fangs in neck though I
want to see blood sprinkling we all want
bread blood spray yes I want blood
sprays
your head's coming on that weird
sexualness of the biting of the neck
well every there's a key and peel sketch
where they're making fun of vampires
that are too sexual when they're doing
things they're like why are you guys
doing all this stuff and I was like that
was Blake that was all blade and I want
it back well that's all like I mean if
you want to get into it that is the
Dracula Mythos that goes all the way
back that is those are the first like
erotica novels right this idea that like
you're you're a lady or a man uh and
this this this Specter comes into your
home
and we're invited hey this is you and
you can't say no no matter how much you
want to you can't say no to him you must
let him
go yeah
and then spit in all of your holes
and you guys wonder why I love Twilight
Twilight they're like if I give you a
little peck on the cheek then you turn
into a vampire
oh
go go to your discussion uh well we keep
saying no super chats if you want us to
reach into the boo bucket yeah you want
to throw back into our boob from our boo
buckets to our poop
Corey can't really say blue bucket isn't
that another word for toilet oh Corey
great minds think a lot hey anything's a
word for toilet if you use it in the
right context uh you can preach a shout
out to mezzo she keeps me in check uh be
kind out shout out to mezzo shout out to
mezzo Zach Braddock why are so many
writers not reading the comics
I mean it's so hard to read a comedy
there's all these pictures it's really
interesting the one with Wanda Vision
was more so like the the you saw one
division the show was mainly more about
TV and Cinema and just like how they can
reflect from the freaking 30s to now so
they mainly were like how can we get
people that are really good at like a
four camera like one room setup versus
knowing knowledge of the comics really
well and I think I think the the writers
do read the comics they just don't want
to come out in an interview and be like
I read every Wanda maximize Comics come
at me with your comment you know it's
like I think it's easier for them to say
like well I haven't read all the comics
because there's a lot if you're just
coming into do a movie and you want to
do a movie about a character that was
created in 1976 right you're gonna be
there all day I got two words
if you hire me to do the job you know I
would but I don't think that's wrong I
think I think what they're asking is
like why aren't they and I think that's
just what it is it's just like they were
hired to write something not completely
like that right unless they were sorry
Wikipedia
okay
go to Wikipedia read character
background origin read common enemies
common uh common friends teams they've
been a part of origin story famous
famous runs you're good yeah 25 minutes
I know everything give me a comic book
character Superman okay Cod Kent born on
the Planet Krypton uh frequently teams
up with Jimmy Olsen okay uh
okay uh frequent enemies
uh the Dairy Queen
the Dairy Queen Baskin Robbins
or he just doesn't like ice it's
Kryptonite magic the scooping screamer
uh Fosters freeze uh the MJ 2997 sending
a super chat I think they have a little
insight into what Rihanna's new song is
going to be they say you think Neymar
could summon a bunch of baby sharks in
the movie
baby shark would be a good song for the
movie maybe Rihanna's gonna sing baby
shark can we not say that because it's a
copyright uh maybe oh okay I don't think
Brandon knows how the song goes I didn't
want to sing it because Brandon was born
when you started singing the song it
unlocks the main church was born in 2002
he would have loved that song because it
would have been 14 when it came out I
don't think 14 year olds online 14 year
olds love baby shark
I hear that their two favorite things to
do are vape and listen to baby sharks Oh
and before we get to our main discussion
Elizabeth see sending in a Super Chat do
you think the greens will take Helena's
dream seriously here's the deal okay but
Sarah
and Allison bought into that right and I
think after what we saw in this most
recent episode potentially the beast
from beneath the board I think Allison
now is going to be very keen on what uh
Helena has to say and Helena was the
only one she wanted to save right oh I
want to go in on this so bad but this is
not talking dragons I don't know what
anyone's talking about
like the My Chemical Romance on
guys are mispronouncing Elena
um black widow sister
same time right yeah okay folks here's
the real deal our main discussion today
there are rumors swirling all over the
internet I mean it's like someone is
just hitting the flush on the toilet and
these rumors are swirling around even
our boy Eric Voss put out a little Ticky
talk uh talking about this okay I'm not
gonna confirm this for you because I
absolutely refuse to confirm a rumor
okay but if you are apt to believe
rumors because maybe you ain't Pig chips
as a child Sasha Baron Cohen is
potentially going to join the MCU as
Mephisto then as I like
in the upcoming Iron Heart series
uh which is which is crazy okay I don't
know if you folks out there even care
about Mephisto but around here it's a
dirty word uh we got our hope set on it
and one division it really seemed like
they were going that way and they took
it away okay now these rumors are coming
out and it seems like this this could be
what happened is happening uh now
ironheart is an interesting series for
him to come out in right because you
know it doesn't seem like a series
that's about
Mephisto Dimensions all that other stuff
magic magic but uh uh Kevin feige at d23
when they were talking about the
ironheart series he pointed out that
it's going to be a series that's about
science versus like dark magic uh and
really this phase is the MCU while it's
like a multiversal phase there's been so
much magic right between like shangshi
when you had all the magic involved
there the the Tallow kind of magic all
the wind moving stuff Earth bending
whatever you want to call it you know we
had Multiverse of Madness obviously like
a lot of magic involved in that film uh
eternals even has like its own sort of
kind of weird magic it's like Space
Magic yeah we have Space robot magic all
this like magical stuff where it's I
feel like a lot of the MCU in the end
game kind of infinity Saga Series right
was about like science and like making
things practical yes you have like
people doing magic but you have like
super soldier serum that makes people
stronger or like uh the pin particle
that gives you Powers they're trying to
explain everything but now it's like is
water magic long story I know but we
know that in Iron Heart right one of the
villains or the main villain is going to
be the hood the hood uh who wears like
this cute little cape and he has like
little magical powers my tape my Cape
now traditionally now traditionally uh
the hood gets his powers from dormammu
in like the dark dimension but we've
kind of covered dormammu in the dark
dimension Dr Strange dealt with that got
him in a logic trap and we know that
doctor strange now is off
hanging out with this this new side
piece clear right hot chick on the
street says jump in this portal with me
you jump in the portal folks don't bend
there yeah you open your third eye you
go into that tunnel and when it opens up
you could it kind of looks like
dormammu's dark dimension right uh so
maybe their explanation here is gonna be
Mephisto does that sound totally insane
no yes
because maybe this is this is like
Mephisto he was like a cryptocurrency 31
division he got prompted
this could be Mephisto he's behind all
of this I don't know like you know
Memphis is a cool character from the
comics but like he's not like Doctor
Doom or or Thanos level villain to me
like you know what I mean like he's kind
of more of an interesting character they
kind of uh the lures people into making
some bad decisions in order to get what
they want or like you know gets people
to make you know Bargains with them I
just feel like I not that I'm saying
that iron
um
Arden heart is not like uh on the level
of long division I'm just saying it's
like introducing him in a TV show not as
I mean at one point we were like maybe
it's gonna be Al Pacino playing Mephisto
at the end of one division maybe he just
comes in as a normal or you know as like
a character a functional character in
this show and we can just have it and
it'll be nice now we have Mephisto and
the MCU maybe it doesn't need to be this
huge event maybe it just needs to be uh
you know the guy who played Borat
you think I'll just play Sasha Baron
Cohen my job yeah
who have everyone talked like that
[Laughter]
it's not like the capital D devil right
he's not like the Christian uh god of
the afterlife Mephisto rules over a
pocket Dimension that is very fiery uh
it's very hell-esque he'll often call it
hell or call it Hades and he takes the
appearance of the the Christian devil or
the abrahamic devil right but he's not
canonically that like we were doing the
research like in Marvel Comics there is
there's like a Yahweh who is like kind
of a Christian God there is like a hell
Dimension that has had many different
people claim to be its ruler uh but we
don't know for sure but mephisto's kind
of like a side character like cosplaying
as the devil uh and as like humans in in
Marvel Comics like we're apt to believe
that he's the devil because he looks
like we've been told what the devil is
and he has like these magical powers so
he could be showing up uh to the hood to
be like I'm here to give you the palace
I'm the devil do what I say in some
versions he also if there are seven
Realms of Hell or seven rings of hell or
what have you he does run one
um even if it's not the actual hell so I
like the idea of him tricking him and
just being like but I want him to be
much more powerful less cartoony and I
think Sasha Baron Cohen can do that it's
just more so like if he's gonna show up
in ironheart
I needed to be serious I needed to be
real and I needed to be strong
um because not I think Marvel does
recognize that people have been asking
for this person for so so long that I
think they'd give him much better and
bigger entrance than just being like
yeah you work under this boy though yeah
yeah there's a guy with some guns they
did kind of tease it in She-Hulk right
in the Donnie Blaze episode if that's
him he makes a part all these like
satanic looking creatures come out the
same that passive I I did the breakdown
so I'm genuinely like it could also be
bassamet because a Baphomet Baphomet it
can also be Baphomet uh there's so much
Lucifer is another demon who like he's
one of the ones that claims to rule hell
uh but they're like it could be him or
he could just be a demon who's like yeah
I'm the ruler yeah yeah there's no proof
that's the thing with and this is what I
love and also hate with the What She
Hulk did was the writers recognized they
were like we can do whatever we kind of
want because we're going to be thrown in
and maybe taken out so that's why they
they leaned at so much X-Men lore as
they're like hey we could not and be on
your side too and I think they did that
by making that hell Donnie Blaze episode
because it was just like oh they're
gonna think it's mephistic they're
they're making fun of us like the
writers for shield were like they're
gonna think it's me Vista they're gonna
make a mebisto and that's why all of the
lore that is in that episode is so
reminiscent of anything that's in hell
not Mephisto it's like none of it is
mephisto's things it's all what the
devil would do and even at the end we
get the like uh courtroom illustration
that is like a devil right like it's the
goat and I'm like okay and I made an
appearance I made I was like hey maybe
Madison drunk thought Mephisto with
goat-like features is the goat is is
this but I was like I think the writers
for She-Hulk were just like this is to
make fun of them but I trust Madison
she's a functional alcoholic yeah I
think that like she knows what's going
on I trust what she has to say yeah I
don't I mean I I'm just saying like hey
I know I'm really drunk sometimes and I
could see a goat and be like it's a goat
or like it's a bear or something stupid
that's the devil yeah like that's the
thing is like I'm not saying that I
don't trust Madison I'm saying that yeah
I've been drunk and I've confused a
raccoon for a cat when I drink I see the
devil in everything
details I love women sorry sometimes on
the show you say women are nice
sometimes on the show what are you
talking
leave it to a woman to put words in my
mouth
I set him up for that I said Jessica you
bring up a good point though that like
there are these there's so many
dimensions and we don't understand so
many of them that like any of them could
just claim to be like now and like I'm
the demon and like again it's much more
easy for them to take advantage of
humans that have been like trained on
the concepts of heaven and how to be
like yeah I'm that thing that you
understand so do as I say uh another
thing I wanted to bring up was the
Wizardry Alchemy necromancy Department
otherwise known as wand
existed no idea which existed as part of
shield and showed up in the comics at
one point and this was like the magic
part of Shield they're like if you've
got a magic problem we're here to solve
it check out the beat by my DJ revolves
that yeah I I swanned yeah it's nice one
baby pretty good so if you have like
Shield you have sword obviously that
deals with like the sentient alien BS
wand was dealing with like the magic
eventually they got the absorbed and
swords deals with space deals with space
now what what okay
one Shield sword or cake which is the
better acronym remember cake stands for
crushing ass killing everyone I mean can
we get a poll for that John what I'm
doing
uh Shield sword wand or cake which is
the best acronym
I go and I think John vapol switched it
up so now we have to switch seats is
that the new thing
oh
yeah
you do it I guess we'll switch some
scenes
yeah
let's not do like they they did yeah so
Mr long says I don't make the rules for
the redempt is she breaking the rules
how dare you fix that camera
oh I can do this one you already did
this one no yeah
um so I'm I'm the motivational the
person's being chased yeah okay all
right let me let me help you out with
some inspiration while you read this I
don't need it
assistant
okay you don't have time you don't have
time do you like scary movies you like
scary movies remember what we learned
from scary movies okay he is ghost face
and what have we learned from any scary
movie we know not to run up the stairs
do not run up the stairs make sure you
have sex before you die because maybe
you won't die first if you're the Virgin
you go first if you're the funny one or
the Virgin you go first and just make
sure you're not both because then you're
just gonna die before he even arrives
make sure that you you don't need a gun
because you don't have enough bullets in
the gun what you need is a knife hear me
out same goes for zombies you need
something that's easier to reload
something that you don't need to reload
and same goes with like a vehicle he's
gonna cut the brakes get a bike you
can't cut the brakes of a bike yeah you
can shut up
if you want to laugh yeah thank you
thank you you guys Ghostface isn't that
hard to kill the spoiler he's a high
school student you can oh I haven't
finished it I'm sorry your 12 years too
late
you can get away from Ghostface I wish
it was 12. oh to her it is you can get
away from Ghost Face you guys can make
it out you can survive this horror film
because at the end of the day teenagers
ain't [ __ ] whoa don't say that to John D
our Millennial producer a German
producer oh yeah and like storm Virgil
said never say I'm getting naked and
taking a shower because then you died
that's a great car have you seen any
Camp movie never take the shower that's
funny every time I do an acting job I'm
like put me in the shower
well I'm up in Chatsworth and all they
have are showers and bed sets that's for
whatever reason
you can be in the shower you could be in
the bed or sometimes a Jacuzzi oh uh
sexy
clogged though
I probably go out with the show today we
want to thank our friends at Magic the
Gathering Arena that's right our good
friends at MTG Arena are bringing the
vast scope of deck building card
collecting and classic game to your
phone or your tablet or your desktop
wherever you like to play those kind of
digital games uh it's the 30th
Anniversary for Magic the Gathering
folks can you believe it's been so long
since we've been subverting our
Christian overlords with the Devil oh
there's also other things that magic the
Gathering not just satanic things good
uh there's like sci-fi decks there's
horror decks there's like cool
futuristic decks maybe they have a
steampunk deck I haven't done the
research but I bet some of the
characters are pretty steampunky uh
Magic the Gathering arena is a great
entry point if you've never played the
game before or maybe you played it for a
long time and then you stopped so now
you can play it again uh all you have to
do is download the game to play on your
mobile phone your tablet or your desktop
anything you want to do uh listen folks
I'm a dum-dum I like easy games Checkers
that's it
Candyland can't lose uh Shoots and
Ladders but so I never really got into
Magic the Gathering because it was hard
you had to read all the cards there's
all these rules always breaking the
rules someone's yelling at me the game
does all the hard work for you which is
like really fun plus uh Magic the
Gathering Arena has an official YouTube
channel where you can check out helpful
videos on how to play you can play with
your friends online you can play with
random people online you can play
against the computer do whatever you
want just get started today by clicking
like in the description below for Magic
the Gathering Arena download for free
and begin assembling Your Dragon deck
today I demand it I'm sorry I did I want
to apologize
did not know it was on a wide I did not
know I always assume you're not a wife
always assume everybody you're always on
what why
ABW I always keep it wide hey whoa yo
hey
hey throw up that picture of Jonathan
Majors again one more time yeah
by the way drink his bath water
whoa you think he takes baths back
wait I came to the shower for hours by
the way it's flexing
you didn't pretty much agreed that cake
was the best yeah crushing ass killing
everyone someone said booty beads is
also an acronym oh my God too many
letters busy always
busy
over
busy over other it's okay honey I'm busy
over other teddy bears what you beat
elephants and Dragons good job honey
it's time for Fannie Brown
look at that graphic this is mandatory
fun
have you never held a microphone before
this is mandatory fun uh I'm gonna do a
motivational Monday motivation about
Ghost Face Killer
AKA Tony Stark hey uh no that's what he
calls himself
come on ghost face where are my Wu-Tang
fans good friend of Raekwon the chef oh
my God I don't know who you got Ghost
Face Raekwon the Giza the Rizza uh Baby
Woo no that he was just a DJ the Red Man
methadone
he's the best you didn't say it well you
didn't let me finish you just you cut
into my naming the Wu-Tang Clan wow
I see he became mean yeah well that's
because I took over your personality
this is the graphic again
I know I feel beautiful when I sit in
this seat uh all right the segment's so
fun we play the graphic more than one
hit it again
yes it's mandatory fun where I gather my
three best friends in the whole world oh
that's great to come have a little fun
with me whether they want to or not
I'm here under duress as is Jessica
apparently lock one more time if you
need me to call the cops now with the
fish jokes possibly coming to the MCU
it's got me thinking about all the
Faustian Bargains I've made in my life
so I want the three of you to think
about and tell me exactly what the terms
would be for you to sell your souls
What's it gonna take for you to join the
devil's Army all right unfortunately oh
a little something came up and I can't
be here today what are you doing that's
so important Dr nasty and my lawyer
Shabazz Shabazz they notified me that
there is actually an eel there's an eel
stomach that I can have transplanted in
now people don't know this eels have
some of the most durable stomachs in the
ocean they can't be punctured by shark
teeth okay don't Google it don't why do
you need that well you know as part of
my quest to perfect my body of course uh
to perfect my Tempo I am having animal
parts put inside of me uh kind of one at
a time
I've had lemur spleens I've had I got a
skunk heart as people know from my uh my
film skunk card attorney at law which uh
I I'm told has a Rotten Tomatoes uh
rating up
[Applause]
uh anyway it gets Brandon every time
I can't be here
but I did find someone that can help
host so you guys think about what your
demonic terms are okay I hope whoever
comes loves me and is not mean to me I
hope so too but I wouldn't count on it I
have something that's funny that eels
have like a stomach that can't be
punctured by sharks so a shark could eat
the rest of the eel but the stomach was
I don't think the living is telling the
truth I don't know would somebody ever
lie to us no his lawyer said it in his
doctor yeah
right now when what happens
uh Corey can't drill it with sending in
a super chat please do a Redemption
where you have to break up with the
Marvel property that's actually a good
idea John write that one down
[Laughter]
I am the Dark Prince of lonely town I'm
the mayor of murderville I am the
governor of
ghouls and ghosts and guts and blood
goblins and goblins
these nuts okay okay
ah yes it's me
God's Fallen buddy the man that God
forgot
and everywhere I go I look for blood in
a pot all right now he's got bars he's
got bars I think he's a member of
Wu-Tang
uh inspector deck rayquan the chef uh we
already set up we went through this yeah
baby yeah yeah
it's nice to know you know the Wu-Tang
also they also have
sort of DJs that are part of their
larger family oh there's a whole it's
like Bone Thugs-N-Harmony in the Mo
Thugs Family Guys okay it's not just the
Bone Thugs people lazy Bone Crazy Bone
Busy Bone understood yes okay flesh and
Bone
all right anyway now
each one of you
it's going to tell
them what it would cost for you to join
my little
Carnival of chaos join me in the depths
of what I like to call
now this is the actual hell this is the
real one this is Hell Michigan oh okay
okay that sounds pretty awesome I own a
little cottage called D Michael town
okay yeah all right so this is one of
the costs dwell magazine recently did an
expose on the team Michael town and they
said did you go
you have Ghosts no oh interesting he has
goats
Okay who wants to know who wants to go
first This Is What It Takes uh you will
give me all these things and you get my
Immortals you tell me what you want I'll
decide if I make the deal and then you
can join my Army of chaos okay yeah Wow
first thing I want is I want like a
little Bread Box okay okay and every
time I open it there's a fresh delicious
and edible
Publix sub oh chicken fingers up no I
don't want that one okay whichever one I
most desire at that moment I get it okay
okay so an assorted sub assorted Subs
okay assorted subs and what else or is
that are you done no that's that's one
thing okay uh I want my uh checking
account to never go below a thousand
dollars
I think that's fair your soul yeah yeah
I'm not done yet okay all right that's
right I mean I've made deals with Elvis
before okay I mean you can only imagine
the amount it doesn't seem like it
worked out well for Elvis that's true I
saw the film
uh I also it was nothing but a hound dog
a Hound of Hell dog oh okay okay bark it
all the time
um I want the Delorean from Back to the
Future Part Two that runs on garbage and
can fly I don't have to go through time
with the Mr Fusion yeah yeah yeah I want
that okay
uh uh I want Blake Lively to give me a
second chance okay she doesn't have to
say yes
two years ago Lively
sucking D's no no that's just second
chance this is a horrible deal
how many things can we list in exchange
for our Motors
nothing okay that's fair uh
that's it that's so worth it all right
team Mephisto bechtold forgot my own
last name there for a second I've agreed
to these terms it will now offer you a
chance to make the deal of a lifetime if
you sign right there oh okay you're not
going to get everybody else's yeah yeah
we'll see maybe they'll get a chance too
I knew he was a problem I was glad I
just had to sign with red marker yeah
you've made a mistake my friend because
you are now one of my Dunes doggies
walking like a dog
next bargain
um
did you take that paper out of your
mouth
I have marker on my tongue
that's how you got to make the deal
though that's what happens team of
Festival you got to see where this one's
going
um I want to be which I'm going to be a
witch I want to be a witch that's one
weekend in Joshua Tree you gotta trade
your soul well I want to be like Wanda
Witch okay okay so it's going to work
out so well for her no problems no no so
I'm guessing your nest this next wish is
not to be a mother I want love oh this
is getting sad
oh the devil's about to go back to his
home in Hell
more girls call his mom affordable rent
for everyone oh okay well now you make
me look selfish
um don't worry I got you okay
um and endless sex
um now does that mean ultimate endurance
or I was gonna say are we talking about
like at this end of the day it's like uh
I gotta go to the bathroom at some point
it's like an avocado that's three days
old wait wait all three of you guys's
opinions I meant I mainly meant like um
could you put endless x with Jonathan
Majors okay okay and
um
maybe it's Jonathan Majors a 77 year old
custodian and Playa Del Mar he deserves
it and I won beats cheeks like an animal
like a drum major with this broomstick
and I want a hug oh I just want to hug
yeah from anyone in particular no no you
could have abolished well
you asked for Club 33. the devil is
willing to take your soul for the first
terms you guys sign here Brett will go
back down to like 200 nice I like that
I should have put payoff student loans
it's too late that looks like now I have
your
souls of hell now
why'd you put mine up your butt I wonder
what the contracts must join my heart
and there's two ways to my heart
down my throat or up my goat all right
now
last but not least Eric yeah what are
your terms to making a deal with the
devil all right all right to think a
long hard about this one I need a
quadruple date
in quadruple day it's gonna be me
um
Zendaya
Megan Good
Lupita Nyong'o oh my God that's that's
that's worth the price of one Immortal
soul I accept your terms you get nothing
else
what else that's it that's it that's the
whole day just one date look those are a
lot of ladies I'm gonna need that
endless stamina uh that Jessica
okay they say that he's Charming
and how okay
um
just sign right here she may say but I'm
gonna work it did well honestly don't
give it back to him he's gonna put in
another weird boxes I want to see though
do you not see this I want to see where
he's All-Star list I mean as long as you
find it I think don't listen to The
Devil's dogs
now you're one of my demon dogs
where did it go
there's something behind your ear
I put in a secret clause in this
contract you may go on your date but D
Michael Bechtel gets to watch on a
hidden camera the whole time
I don't see anything wrong with that
take that Brazzers I don't need a
subscription anymore music Vixen said it
doesn't mean that they're gonna have sex
oh if I know Megan good and I don't
she's doing it on the first day
anyway that's been mandatory fun maybe a
poll maybe a ball maybe a pole oh the
devil loves a good Paul I'm out of here
we love a good super chat bye devil my
name
uh yeah thank you to all our super
Chatters today Corey kendrilla put you
out earlier but he pointed out 305 sharp
which we aim to please 305 sharks uh
Christian unpronounceable asking for
musical redemptions you know we haven't
sung in a while on the show
[Music]
that night that night yet maybe earlier
hey guys oh we did sing George's name
off titles
how does everyone do it oh hey what's up
man how's your stomach yes
well they didn't tell me it was going to
be a really huge eel Oh I thought I was
gonna get like almost like a little
bonus gastric bypass for this where I
just have a tiny stomach but this eel
was like nine feet long oh [ __ ] I'm
mostly eel stomach
that's a good deal uh Mikey cheers
standing in a Super Chat pointing out
there were definitely Kang variants in
the sky at the end of no way home Green
Goblin responsible for breaking time
there could have been King Branch I mean
I guess we don't know
I'll buy it I'll buy it I'll buy that
for a dollar you could pre-test saying
last house of the Dragon was like my
meat to my feet
what would be the most disgusting food
for me to order from GrubHub before I
watch this episode
I think just like some cream filled
Donuts
I want to be one of Tommy's besties too
for mandatory finals okay well you are
as one of the devil's dogs I want to
tell you it's always a great deal
listen to me
you can be one of my besties for a price
for a price Quentin we ran our poll
asking what the best uh acronym was he
liked corn or like corn he said Adidas
oh all day I dream about soccer or maybe
something else that starts with an S
Scientology I hope not okay uh if you're
out there and you're in Scientology get
out
yeah but keep watching the show and
super chatting we know you like to give
money yeah responsibly
well we're losing our Scientologist
audience uh uh thank you Michael
Matt Wolverine saying candy corn is the
goat of Halloween candy it is
several times this month already at the
office candy corn is okay the pumpkins
are better though no they taste the same
no they do not taste the same dude it's
like pumpkins and if you got psls you
can put some of those pumpkins down you
know post Hayes I'm sorry what you
aren't you aren't here
are you saying we got pumpkin sucking
lips
the quiz Master said the quiz Master
told us that I don't know and he's in
jail
Clemens fragirl doing us a favor uh
she's from HR and she rolled a not 20 so
you all get your souls back thanks John
oh all right but I'll keep the ears
these are flying yeah yeah like these
all right Megan go to like these
not gonna be happy but I have no horse
in this race there you go and you can
free to also pointing out remember kids
look both ways before crossing the
street whatever happened to the PBS
messages at the end of cartoons GI right
and then she goes for John
John
he's too young he doesn't know that yeah
he's like What's that the only cartoons
I know or Paw Patrol
Bluey Bluey just dog based puppy dog
Pals puppy dog Pals vampirina he's not a
dog Bubble Guppies
Shimmer and shine
I don't know my niece is like shimmery
that old Shimmer and shine is huge heavy
metal
first I think that it was like when
you're talking to your parents like it's
a cartoon I can watch it it's fine yeah
it's like when I told my aunt that kids
was a movie about kids and it was
it is
you so badly want to watch kids like not
a fun R-rated movie to get into yeah
well I mean listen I was 34.
uh thank you folks for tuning today we
hope you had a great Monday here someone
already said prove it like goodbye was
like I don't want to do this I'm gonna
start doing their goodbyes and hopefully
they end the stream uh make sure you
guys tune in tomorrow we'll be having a
new round of fantasy picks for episode
of Android this week uh check out
talking dragons uh on the channel if you
haven't already and you like to watch
House of the Dragons uh Jessica's done
all her She-Hulk breakdowns but she has
a play breakdown come on I'm done
forever now I I once I turned 30 I
disappear forever oh I'm like Jeepers
Creepers nine years
which one is it
some [ __ ] it's always trying to
ice skate up a hill yeah okay okay I'm
not supposed to say this I'm not
supposed to say this because it's in my
breakdown exclusive
came up with that what's up
I don't know why it's in the movie
because it makes no sense I don't I
don't want to accuse
the great Wesley Snipes of plagiarizing
but doesn't that sound like something an
old crazy person said to him in a bar
one oh yeah he's like well Wesley let me
tell you I've been in this town 900
years because he's also a vampire of
course some [ __ ] are always
trying to escape
I'm gonna play blade in a movie and this
was in 1974. I'm 12. I'm gonna use this
in a blade movie someday go back and
check all those films he said in
terminal velocity
White Men Can't Jump
uh but thank you guys for tuning in
today uh be sure to like the video if
you haven't already
subscribe subscribe to the channel we
know some of you aren't subscribed do it
please subscribe so we'll send team
Mephisto back to okay and all that
Comic-Con things have been mailed okay
oh nice just look at yo you have seven
to ten weeks until they get there
because we mailed them did you mail it
to me
[Applause]
hi
foreign